avant la colonisation les oiseaux
nichent dans les vieux armes dans les
gros arbre au tronc fait graduellement
ce type de débiteurs aussi diminué
beaucoup avec la déforestation pour
faire place aux villes aux champs
agricoles donc puis se sont rabattus sur
les cheminées qui sont commandés habito
compare un peu un vieux troncs d'arbres
dans une structure en os dents creuses
qui recherchent probablement dans les
cheminées
c'est comme un endroit on peut dire
sécuritaire donc à l'abri des prédateurs
à l'abri du vent du froid de la pluie
on y retrouve sur dans une cheminée donc
c'est pour ça que graduellement les
martin avaient colonisé les cheminées